louis y kate tienen dos videojuegos que
desean jugar tienen planeado jugar a
ambos videojuegos exactamente durante 45
minutos desean utilizar una ecuación que
exprese la relación entre los minutos
que pasan jugando hombre bolonia y los
minutos que pasen jugando debes cortar
el cable puede ser representada mediante
una ecuación lineal dicha relación
veamos si se puede así que vamos a
definir algunas variables primero
definiremos una variable para la
cantidad de tiempo o los minutos que
pasan jugando hombre bolonia entonces
decimos que x es igual al tiempo que
pasan jugando hombre bolonia tiempo
jugando
vamos a ponerle bolonia
después definimos allí
como la cantidad de tiempo o los minutos
que pasan jugando
debes cortar el cable
entonces ya es el tiempo jugando
y lo pondré como cable
en los minutos que pasaron jugando
hombre bolonia y tenemos los minutos que
pasarán jugando cortar debes cortar el
cable si lo sumamos entonces tenemos x +
x +
y el más lo pondré en un color neutro
bien
cuál será el resultado de esta suma
el tiempo que pasan jugando hombre
bolonia más el tiempo que pasan jugando
debes cortar el cable debe ser
ellos tenían planeado jugar ambos
videojuegos exactamente durante 45
minutos así que la suma debe ser igual a
45 minutos ahora hemos construido una
ecuación que representa la relación del
tiempo que jugará nombre bolonia y el
tiempo que jugarán debes cortar el cable
pero la pregunta es será esta una
ecuación lineal
una forma de comprobarlo es tratar de
reescribir la ecuación en la forma
tradicional de la ecuación de una recta
así que debemos reescribir la en la
forma de igual a mx más vez donde m es
la pendiente y ve la ordenada al origen
intentémoslo para dejar la equis del
lado derecho de la ecuación vamos a
restar x por ambos lados entonces
restamos x de este lado
x
- x + x se cancela
y quedaría ye igual
a 45 - x
y escribiré el menos x primero
ye igual
a menos x
a los 45
para respetar la forma tradicional de la
ecuación
todo lo que hicimos fue intercambiar
estos dos términos
yo puedo ver que la relación tiene la
forma de la ecuación tradicional de la
recta sin embargo tú puedes preguntar
dónde está la m
pero esta ecuación es lo mismo que
escribir 10
igual a menos 1 x
donde la pendiente de la dm sería menos
+ 45
así que fuimos capaces de reescribir lo
en la forma tradicional de la ecuación
de una recta y por lo tanto la pregunta
puede ser representada mediante una
ecuación lineal dicha relación es sí